hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to in two
minutes now I'm not sure if you've heard
but fallout 4s coming out later this
year probably one of gaming's worst kept
secrets the sequel to Bethesda's
post-apocalyptic RPG was officially
announced before e3 along with
confirming the much rumored Boston
setting but there's two spoiled details
starved vault dwellers by releasing a
gameplay trailer before the dusk who
said on that Megaton it dropped another
by announcing in November tenth release
date just a few days later at e3 which
is just under five months from reveal to
release which in this day and age of
extended PR cycles is completely unheard
of generally the marketing machine is
pumping its hardest while games are in
an unfinished state hence why we
frequently get CGI trailers designed to
pitch a vision instead of show us a
gameplay reality as the game becomes
more whole we get things like press
demos and hands-on at events and trade
shows these are usually accompanied by
screenshots and videos drip feeding us
information and new reveals along the
way it's a lengthy process that carries
as much risk of numbing people to a game
as it does building hype for it Bethesda
has bucked this trend by throwing that
well-worn cycle out into the wasteland
and if you ask me fallout 4 is
benefiting in a big way because of it
but there's this marketing bot Pete
Hines recently revealed that fallout 4
was basically done before it even got
announced which explains why it's been
able to show so much of what is
basically the finished game it also
means pathetic can have a short a
promotion cycle where it pulls a bunch
of marketing tricks that build intense
hype and then be in a position to
capitalize on that by releasing when
it's at fever pitch instead of
screenshots of individual character
models and various landscapes which
let's face it are pretty boring we've
had a tie-in mobile game that made 5
point 1 million dollars in just two
weeks and that's not even accounting for
the android market
there was no overwhelming multi retailer
pre-order campaign either just one
special edition a real-life Pip Boy
which proved to be so popular that
Bethesda literally can't manufacture
enough to meet demand
since its debut we've had a bunch of big
gaming conventions which would be the
perfect place to show more of the game
and yet Bethesda is opting to keep it
under wraps until they want to I don't
know about you but I think it makes
fallout 4 seem more exciting purely
because I don't know every last detail
about it on paper but Fez does marketing
strategy was all wrong but if you stand
back and really look at it the short
turnaround from announced to release has
been far more effective than a year-long
campaign ever could be but we'll
fallouts bold approach change the
marketing game from now on I guess time
will tell if it's the end of extended PR
and marketing campaigns as we know them
I'm not sure but I do find it exciting
when publishers kind of go against the
grain like this let me know what you
think in the comments box below or find
me on Twitter I'm a Lucy James game I'll
see you next time
you